[Music]
everybody's waiting on those twins but
you know what in the meantime mama keeps
moving it was a busy weekend for the
superstar singer including a stop at her
mother's star-studded charity event
Saturday night Louisiana shoot me here
tonight okay she's coming out what she
is you know my mom I'm gonna get her if
she does it you do not mess with Mama
Tina even if you are queen bee she
slayed with a huge floral crown and a
double baby bump hugging red gown pretty
and pink princess blue IV also on hand
as was jay-z all to support Tina who has
been like a mom to Beyonce's Destiny's
Child bandmates it's usually me
supporting them so they were all hands
on deck for this so many people came out
to support it's just awesome the benefit
raised close to a million dollars for
the new Waco theatre Center in LA
established by Tina and her husband
Richard Lawson a proud reflective
Beyonce captioned this group shot with
Kelly and sister Solange mom you inspire
us all but the do likely next month diva
also came to sell I'm killing myself
she's gonna move until the last day huh
she's gonna keep going to the last day
you know what my sister likes to have
fun man so we're just not treating her
like a pregnant lady like she's likes to
have fun clearly not partied out from
Jessica Alba's prints and Michael
Jackson themed birthday party the night
before later be in a sparkling silver
jacket we see a girl and Kelly were
spotted leaving the big bash at the
peppermint Club mrs. Carter rounded out
her weekend courtside catching the
Clippers with Jay who kept tabs on the
twins who we cannot wait to me
you